good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
Thanksgiving week here in the United
States so today I thought I would share
with you a story of gratitude so several
months ago Sara got me tickets to see
the musical Hamilton in New York City
and I should say that Sara and I are
both huge fans of Hamilton like we've
listened to the cast recording hundreds
of times and now we were going to have
this once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
see the show with the original cast and
we were gonna go to some art galleries
and visit all our favorite places from
back when we were first married and
lived in New York so we got to the
airport a little early and hooray our
flight was on time so we settled into an
airport bar for some snacks and we were
debating whether I should direct message
wind Manuel Miranda who'd not to brag
follows me on Twitter and generally just
feeling sort of giddy and then I took a
bite of my sandwich and more or less
immediately knew that we were not going
to see Hamilton after all a bit of
relevant background I have this weird
disease called the EO Sena philic
esophagitis basically I have this mild
ish inflammation of my esophagus which
usually is not a problem but then very
occasionally food will get stuck part of
the way down my esophagus and that's a
real bummer because when it happens I
can't even successfully swallow my own
spit so I just sort of throw up every
two or three minutes for several hours
until a doctor sticks a tube down my
throat and clears the blockage so okay I
can't even peel away all the layers of
luck and privilege that led to this
moment of misfortune in the Indianapolis
Airport the ability to afford a Broadway
show in a trip to New York City the joy
of a spouse who loves you enough to get
you Hamilton tickets access to excellent
medical care so your esophageal blockage
is an inconvenience rather than a
catastrophe the list goes on and on but
still I was pretty bummed out when we
had to leave the airport and go to the
hospital now of course it wasn't hard to
find a happy home for our Hamilton
tickets and the airline thank you Delta
was amazingly cool about refunding our
tickets but yeah I was still in a pretty
foul mood partly because I was vomiting
every two minutes and partly because I
don't love being reminded that what I
think of as myself is in fact wholly
dependent upon an unreliable and
unpredictable machine called my body
okay so after several hours at the
hospital a woman named Carmen came by to
transport my hospital bed and me to the
endoscopy room along the way she asked
if I had kids and I said yeah and she
said it's nice that your wife can stay
with you as you go through this and I
was like well we're supposed to be on
vacation together and then she said
maybe after you guys get home tonight
you can watch a movie together and I was
like maybe and then she said so you're
married and you have kids do you like
your job and I said yeah
and then she says well you've got the
basics covered and then I was in the o.r
and then I was unconscious and then I
could swallow again and I woke up
thinking well
got the basics covered that night Sara
and I went home and watched a movie it's
a pretty good movie actually since then
I thought about that day and Carman many
times I love my friends and family and I
am loved by them I've got the basics
covered okay so flash-forward six months
to last week we've just started filming
our new health and fitness show 100 days
starting January 1st you can watch my
best friend Kris and I try to have a
healthy midwife crisis over at
youtube.com / 100 days anyway as part of
the show we have to exercise six days a
week often at very odd hours because of
our work schedules so last Wednesday I
had to wake up at 5:10 in the morning to
go to a spin class and I was not psyched
about it so I walk into this spin class
and there's Carmen and she says hey Jon
remember me and I say yeah and she says
I'm your spin instructor this is what I
do before work and of course it turned
out to be an excellent spin class so
this Thanksgiving I am grateful to
Carmen when you are kind to strangers
you never know what its gonna mean to
them but sometimes it means a great deal
so Thank You Carmen Happy Thanksgiving
and the screen here you'll find some old
Thanksgiving Z vlogbrothers videos as
well as a self-care bunny from rosianna
who is here to remind you that Carmen
thinks you're awesome and she knows from
awesome